first-generation students come with a
unique experience because they don't
have the family members and the
background to draw off of in terms of
thinking about how to navigate the
college experience so they don't have
that person that can turn back to that
they trust and they know to ask
questions or just to hear the stories of
I remember when as a first-generation
college student I know what you're going
through I know the doubts that you might
have I know the courage that it takes to
overcome those doubts and I just want to
tell you I've been there myself and
Carnegie Mellon is dedicated to ensuring
that everyone has access to higher
education and high quality education we
work hard to make sure that we provide
the support that first-generation
college students need to navigate their
journey our Center for student diversity
and inclusion is the place where our
first-generation students can gather to
be successful and have the best college
experience that you can the center
provides support in three different ways
so the first way is to provide them a
place to meet up with other
first-generation students to share
experiences who address problems that
they face and just to make a connection
with others who are going through the
same thing
the second way the Center supports
students is by connecting them with
faculty and staff who can answer
questions help them navigate through the
university and just figure out how to
get around and the third way for
prospective students our weekends that
we have are we invite our
first-generation students to come
explore campus at their own pace and ask
those questions that they may feel
uncomfortable asking in front of others
who have a deeper network in support of
their college experience Carnegie Mellon
is a better place for having
first-generation college students on
campus you bring a set of experiences
that others may not have and it together
through our shared experiences and the
diversity of our experiences we're going
to be able to learn
develop create grow and change the world
[Music]
you